so what was it like working with two
legendary folks like will in Martin very
surreal man I mean I grew up watching
Will and Martin and - and I grew up
watching the bad boys franchise to be a
part of it is very surreal man no I
haven't seen the movie but I hear the
younger folks give the older guys a lot
of grief in this movie is that true we
do we do
Oh old school versus the new school so
you'll see a little fun stuff between
will and I so okay so I want to know
off-camera did you give those old guys a
little grief yeah and you know it's
having a little fun on set yeah yeah you
did you miss me a little bit I miss with
Martin a little bit more than anybody
else by me it's all fun really really
what is it like being in it you talk
about seeing these movies what's it like
being in an iconic franchise like this I
mean it's a blessing you know to learn
from some of the best and to just kind
of soak in and just be a sponge around
great talent and just great human beings
man like I learned so much it's just an
actor and it's just a human being all
right well what I want to know is did
you ever get out cuz you know will has
these legendary workouts did you get up
and work out with will did he ever try
to get you to work out with him you know
the funny thing is will like built this
gym at the studio that we were filming
at and we just shadowbox it a little bit
for like the first day but that was the
last time I was in the gym you shadowbox
with will kind of it was for like ten
seconds but enough for me to go yeah a
shuttle bus with will so you didn't
throw a punch it will you just ya know
now that's oh gee Mohammed I leave and I
can't be doing that
[Music]